we have a voicemail number it's two one
nine two david p the Eggman called in
making a point about sexual harassment
allegations I guess hi Dave you know the
old saying kill one person you're a
murderer
but killed ten thousand people you're a
political hero I think that same saying
goes in politics for rape carcasses rape
one person you're a rapist rape
seventeen people your president right
III think that that's there's definitely
something there and I it's not quite so
simple but I do believe that in the end
if people want to ignore sexual assault
allegations including child rape they'll
ignore them up to and including voting
the accused person into the Oval Office
because we have a president with more
than a dozen sexual assault allegations
against them I do wonder if I mean
there's only maybe one allegation or two
allegations if some people see that is
more credible than if there's ten or
fifteen because they believe it's I
don't know I'm sure that that exists but
I don't I'm not convinced by that I
don't think that that's good sound logic
I don't know I don't think there's any
reason I certainly don't see more and
more allegations pile up and say oh now
I think the person's probably not guilty
some people just think it's a conspiracy
by the liberal media yeah
of course and it absolutely is no I'm
kidding but yeah Roy Moore literally
said that actually he said I believe
that this is a liberal media conspiracy
to hurt my candidacy and it's like
mostly Republican women that are coming
out who always vote for Republicans who
seem to have had absolutely no financial
gain from doing this whatsoever and some
of whom have actually said I'm worse off
now I saw an interview today actually I
believe with uh with MS Curfman who said
this has not been good for me coming
over it hasn't been good on the bonus
show today Donald Trump soft spot for
Elephants is that true and also can
police use your ancestry.com or 23andme
data to try to get your DNA the answer
is kind of yes sort of we will talk
about it on the bonus show and what
should the next jenga style thing be
that we do people love the Jenga tower
and we will discuss some of the ideas
that came in for the next game to play
two ways to get access to the bonus show
david pakman.com slash membership and
patreon.com slash david pakman show
shorter week this week wednesday will be
like the friday show because of the
thanksgiving holiday